very good morning welcome to Sky News
breakfast thanks for joining us now
passengers are being told to expect
disruption at six of the UK's busiest
airports today as border force staff
become the latest sector to join a wave
of industrial action now the strike
involves around a thousand workers who
operate passport booths at airports
including Heathrow Gatwick Manchester
Glasgow and Cardiff there are warnings
that arriving passengers could face long
queues even longer than normal and may
even be held on planes to prevent
crowding in terminals as the military
and civil servants are drafted in to
help cover Sky's shingy mararike reports
another day another strike in this
winter of walkouts
this time it's the Border Force
potentially grounding parts of Britain's
biggest airports and one Seaport
about 1 000 members of Staff who operate
possible booths taking action over pay
jobs pensions and conditions their Union
the PCS are asking for a 10 rise
something members like Jack say is a
must as this cost of living crisis
worsens
we've got people who can't afford to go
to work they can't afford to put the
fuel in the car or they're struggling to
pay the heating bill in Winter we're in
such an unprecedented position at the
moment and for the government to say to
us we want you to take a 10 pay cut is
something we can't afford not to take
action on
that action could come at a cost to
Travelers too in the first festive
period without covert travel
restrictions since the pandemic
Aviation data company serum said
1290 flights are scheduled to land at
affected airports today on the first day
of industrial action over total capacity
of more than a quarter of a million
passages
over the course of these strikes the
airports affected are scheduled to see a
total of 8910 arrivals equating to over
1.7 million seats
strike action by borderful staff at
airports means people will be looking to
travel from other terminals like Saint
Pancras it's a wave of industrial action
part of a December of disruption that's
starting to divide opinion
that's going to cause a lot of stuff
like a lot of
trouble to not just for like the
individuals but for their families it's
going to cause extra stress it's really
exciting to see action being taken and
workers sort of uniting to demand better
pay and better conditions from their
employers
earlier this week those demands were
made by ambulance staff meaning the
military stepped in just like they do
again today at the pools
with the Border Force walkout taking
place every day except one until the new
year we now have more travel disruption
added to the bigger picture concrete
interpreters
shinki marike Sky News
guys Becky Cottrell is at Gatwick
Airport for US this morning good morning
to Becky another military and civil
servants have been drafted in to help
with this strike action today by border
Force what's the situation at Gatwick
well it's still quite early in the
morning the peak time for incoming
flights from International destinations
is lunchtime and evening so it's still a
bit wait and see at the moment but I've
spoken to the airport this morning and
they say passengers shouldn't be too
worried yet at worst they could expect
Hughes maybe around one to two hours but
they don't expect cancellations maybe
delays they can kind of arrange the uh
the times that flights arrive so the
queues don't build up too much but
certainly no cancellations expected at
the moment and the advice from airports
other airports too is that passengers
should use the e-gates if they can
you're of course can only use those if
you have a biometric passport not
everyone can use those including
children under 12 but as you said there
will be members of the military and the
Civil Service stepping in to check
passports in person these strikes have
been targeted at a very busy time of
year Christmas a lot of people wanting
to get away maybe to warmer destinations
especially after the uncertainty we've
had over the past couple of years with
the pandemic and these strikes will take
place over six days between now and the
end of the year they are hitting
Britain's biggest airports Gatwick
Heathrow Birmingham Cardiff Glasgow and
Manchester but as I say at the moment
the airport is saying let's wait and see
and passengers shouldn't be too worried
okay Becky for now thank you Becky
Cottrell across the situation at Gatwick
for us this morning and of course those
order four strikes are just the latest
in a wave of industrial action this
winter this is where things stand as we
approach the end of the month and head
into the new year so borderforce staff
who are members of the PCS Union well
they're on strike almost every day now
between now and New Year's Eve Royal
Mail workers will be back on the picket
line again both today and Saturday
the rmt union will stage more rail
strikes from Christmas Eve until the
27th of December
ambulance workers will have their second
strike on the 28th of the month
National highways employees are striking
today with more planned action later in
the week
and January strikes confirmed so far
include paramedics on the 11th and the
23rd of the month and whale workers will
walk out to between the third and the
7th of January
now the Royal College of Nursing is set
to announce the dates of further new
strikes in January to later today after
making a final appeal to the government
to get around the negotiating table or
we can bring in our political
correspondent Ali fortiscu for more on
this certainly a perfect storm of
strikes uh this month and over the
Christmas period alien it certainly
feels like the pain is not going to be
overcome the new year
no I think things will get worse because
the whole point of strike action is to
escalate to dial up the action until the
government really feels oppression that
is why ambulance strikes next month will
be longer will involve more people as
you say
um there were we understand according to
the Union's no talks between the health
secretary and the unions yesterday which
means that we expect today new days
dates for nurses strikes will be
announced and the public the NHS strikes
are particularly dangerous for the
government not just because of the
obvious practical implications but
because there is a degree of public
sympathy polling suggests among Tory
voters too so there is a danger
obviously for the government and there
aren't a huge number of options we know
that we saw an effect in Olive Branch
yesterday as a health secretary spoke
about the pay review body process for
next year suggesting there could be
payroll sizes in the spring but not
talking about changing anything right
now and that obviously hasn't been
enough for the unions they say that
they've faced real terms pay cuts over a
long period of time the governments say
um that this is about trying to keep
down inflation and both sides are miles
apart when it comes to talking about a
deal on nurses for example the
government talking about less than five
percent the unions talking about 19 we
saw in Scotland that they're off of 6.5
didn't manage to avert future strike
action wasn't a deal that was reached
with the unions so you can see there
just how far the government would have
to go if they were to try to stop these
strikes from happening so it is
difficult for the house secretary it's
difficult for the Prime Minister too
he's been accused of being missing
missing in action not showing leadership
I think he wants to show that he's tough
on the unions he's talked about tougher
laws for the unions but in the shorter
medium term that is going to probably
not change anything and as the strikes
escalate and really start to have an
impact on people's lives that position
is going to get harder to hold
okay Ali for now thank you
well returning to those border Force
strikes now and workers have started a
week of industrial action over Christmas
and into New Year's Eve well Adam Jones
is head of Passenger operations and
services at Gatwick Airport a very good
morning to you thank you for joining us
now this is just the first day of strike
action by border force staff only
working one day now between now and New
Year's Eve how much disruption are you
expecting at Gatwick
well I've just come from the border
where everything's working smoothly with
the contingent staff in place we expect
passport checks to take a bit longer and
we do anticipate some disruption but
flights are operating normally arrivals
and departures and we expect that to
continue
and who are Manning the booze that
passport control at Gatwick today
so there are border force staff who are
not striking members of the Armed Forces
and volunteers from across the home
office who have been trained to operate
the Border we also have the 25 e-gates
in each terminal they're operating
normally for those of the biometric
passport
how much training um have the military
had to take care of passport control
you'd need to ask border force that who
operate the Border they've been
conducting the training and the
familiarization but their staff are on
the border right now and it's operating
smoothly
are you about the
terms of who will be most affected
during these strikes
so at really busy periods we think the
disruption May extend to up to two hours
at the border just at the peak times as
I said anyone who can use egates is
advised to use them it's the quickest
way across the border we will have extra
Gatwick staff in the immigration Halls
helping people get to the right desks or
the e-gate and also providing welfare
support to any passengers who are having
to wait for extended periods
which passengers are able to use those
e-gates and which ones we'll have to cue
yes so anyone with a biometric symbol on
their passport the passport holder has
to be 12 years or over and the people
from the UK EU countries America Canada
Australia New Zealand and a few other
countries are able to use them and our
concierge staff and immigration Hall
will Point those people to the e-gates
then get across the border as quickly as
possible
and is most disruption going to impact
passengers who are inbound inbound to
the UK what about passengers also
departing on flights over the next few
days are they going to have to leave
extra time as well
no we expect no impact on departing
batteries at all or those arriving into
the airport from other UK airports the
Republic of Ireland the Channel Islands
or the Isle of Man
the sense of how big
how big could be at Gatwick and across
other airports in the UK
so today is the first day of the strike
so we'll really find out how it works
today as I said we do advise passengers
to be ready for queuing it could be up
to two hours so please be prepared bring
some food and water ask our staff if you
need any assistance but we are confident
the airport will operate as normal and
flights will arrive and depart on time
now is there a risk that airports like
Gatwick could be forced to close during
these strikes and what would be your
message to the unions and to the
government
so we absolutely see no risk of the
airport shutting the board will remain
open it is resourced by the contingency
staff and we have plans in place if
queuing gets excessive just to control
the amount of traffic coming into the
airport
in terms of the strike itself we just
encourage all the parts involved to
reach a resolution as soon as possible
okay Adam Jones we appreciate your time
today and best of luck with the coming
days thank you
thank you
and later this hour we'll be speaking to
Mark saw what could the head of the PCS
Union which represents striking border
force staff
let's take a look at some of the day's
other headlines now and the ministry of
justice has ordered a formal review into
how a quadruple murderer was handled by
probation officers on Wednesday Damien
Bendel was sentenced to a whole life
term in jail for killing three children
and his pregnant partner in
killamarshness Sheffield last year
Bendel was already in the probation
system for arson robbery attempted
robbery and Grievous bodily harm
convictions
foreign
Scottish government has warned
Westminster it would challenge any
attempt to block controversial gender
reforms that would allow transgender
people to self-identify the Secretary of
State for Scotland Alastair Jack said
the UK government could seek to block
the gender recognition reform Scotland
Bill becoming law after it was passed by
on Thursday
charity shops are seeing booming trade
as budget squeezed Shoppers search for
second-hand Christmas gifts the British
Heart Foundation says it's had its
biggest ever week while Revenue has also
up for bernardo's age UK and cancer
research UK
U.S cryptocurrency entrepreneur Sam
bankman freed has been released on a 250
million dollar Bond his parents signed
the agreement and said they'd keep him
at their California home as he awaits
trial
bankman freed is accused of swindling
investors and looting customer deposits
on his FDX trading platform which
collapsed
an Amber traffic warning's been issued
on the roads for today and tomorrow as
millions of drivers are expected to join
the annual Christmas getaway the AAA is
warning motorists to prepare for long
delays which could be compounded by
strikes on railways well it's estimated
around 16.9 million Journeys will be
made on UK roads today which the AAA
says will be the busiest day this week a
further 16.6 million trips are expected
to be made tomorrow
and analytics suggests Journey times
will be around 14 longer compared with
the same period last year
well Skies Shimon Freeman Powell is by
the M25 in Surrey Forest which is
expected to be one of the busiest roads
today very good morning to you shiman
many people dread the Christmas getaway
most years is always fairly chaotic with
so many people on the roads but it
sounds like today and this festive
period could be even worse than normal
yes that's why it's expected to be the
busiest traveling period since 2019 so
pre-pandemic really and that's probably
because more and more people are now
taking the opportunity to go and see
family members across the country but
the AAA are warning that drivers May
well face lots of traffic as they hit
the roads throughout the course of today
and tomorrow now as you say today is
expected to be the busiest period on the
roads with around 16.9 million Journeys
expected to be made over the course of
today and tomorrow will be busy too but
not as busy with around 16.6 million
Journeys expected to be made but it is
likely to be even busier because of
those train strikes the rmt union and
some of the members represented by the
rmt union and network rails striking and
that means that trains will likely to
end around midday tomorrow and the AAA
said that they believe that around half
of people that usually would have gone
where they've used trains to be able to
travel around the country will now
either get in their own cars to make
those Journeys or ask a friend for a
lift now I do have uh some of the roads
that will be most affected by congestion
that will be the M25 the M60 near
Manchester the m6 the M40 in Oxfordshire
they're all the roads the main roads
that are expected to have heavier
congestion than usual and on top of that
we've also got planned strike action by
national highways as well they're the
people that help drive us out if there
are accidents on the road so they'll do
things like clothes lanes and direct
passengers so they know the the easiest
roads to be able to travel on now some
of those will be striking in London and
in the southeast of the country which
means that if a car does break down on
these roads it may take a little bit
longer for them to be able to get that
help so the main advice is for drivers
to make sure that they're well equipped
and prepared as they may be faced with
longer Journeys than usual okay Shimon
thanks so much for bringing us up that
update go and stay warm somewhere won't
you
now as many as 135 million Americans are
being warned about a massive winter
storm stretching across the U.S
forecasters say an Arctic bomb site
clone is likely to form as the bad
weather moves over the Great Lakes
now the coldest weather seen enveloping
Canada and the US is shown here in
purple and temperatures could plunge as
low as minus 40 degrees in some places
driven by ferocious wind chill wind
chills our U.S correspondent James
Matthews has more
in these conditions the Christmas
getaway isn't getting very far
this Arctic Storm blowing through North
America has sent temperatures plummeting
closing roads and canceling thousands of
flights this was the scene at Denver
Airport where passengers were left
strandy once I found out
Airlines here managed to find one and
got my flight resolved and I'll be
flying out tomorrow now and just
crashing here for the evening I got on
the bus to come from Boulder to the
airport and a halfway here our our play
was canceled so now we're here this was
a tweet posted by a State Trooper in
Kansas struggling in the snow you can
stay home and not have to travel please
do not try ever
very short you have to travel really
really slow to be able to stay within
the roadway because you cannot see where
the roadways at
tens of millions of people are living in
areas subject to a weather warning
forecasters are predicting the coldest
festive season for decades
concerns of course extend beyond
Christmas traffic
the severe cold brings with it a danger
to life
in Portland Oregon officials have
declared a state of emergency opening
extra shelters for homeless people
I'd particularly with the cold one of
the things that can be dangerous is
people can be laying on the sidewalk or
sleeping outside and you don't always
realize just how dire of a situation
that you're in
as the white out blew in yesterday the
White House issued a travel warning
please take this storm extremely
seriously
and I don't know whether your boss was
elected but if you all have travel plans
to leave now
not not a joke I'm sending my staff
my staff if they have plans to leave on
tomorrow it's not late tonight or
tomorrow tell them we'll leave now
TV providers have advised customers to
download Christmas entertainment in case
of power Cuts here the National Weather
Service is calling this a once in a
generation weather event it is the very
dark cloud over Christmas
James Matthews Sky News in Washington
the U.S committee investigating last
year's January the sixth Capital riots
has released its final
845-page report in the last few hours
now it accuses Donald Trump of engaging
in a multi-part conspiracy to overturn
the lawful results of the 2020
presidential election
adding that the events of the 6th of
January would not have happened without
Donald Trump who many others followed
and his decision to falsely declare
Victory on the night of the election
they say was premeditated
welcome back you're watching Sky News
breakfast it's great to have you with us
now can Christmas angels have brown skin
that was the question posed by then
seven-year-old Sophia to her mother as
they decorated their Christmas tree back
in 2018. now on a mission to make
Christmas more inclusive it prompted
them to create Britain's first
collection of ethnically diverse
decorations Ashner hurry and I went to
meet them
Christmas trees are full of trinkets
packed with memories but the juval and
Burton family trees have some
particularly special editions
decorations created by them that look
just like them I like Aretha
queen of soul so you can add some soul
to your tree so she's one of my
favorites
that just started with an unexpected
question from then seven-year-old Sophia
we were hanging decorations on our tree
in 2018 and she turned and said Can
Christmas angels have brown skin and of
course I was a little bit shocked I've
said of course they could have brown
skin but she had never seen an angel
with brown skin in fact we were actually
hanging up white Angels white elves
white Santa and I thought ah and so it
wasn't until she said that that a Eureka
moment went into my head and I thought
actually why isn't my tree
representative and so Britain's first
ever collection of ethnically diverse
Christmas decorations was born there's
Angels wise men and of course the main
man himself Natalie and Alison design
each character they're then created
packed and shipped across the UK
[Music]
this one is going to
um somewhere near Scotland
the founders say the decorations are for
everyone and can be used to gently nudge
difficult discussions some people find
it daunting to have conversations about
race and color but you know just by what
you introducing to your household
whether it be the books that you read
the films you watch with your children
or even having diverse decorations on
your tree helps to facilitate that
conversation about race and to normalize
these in the household and for them not
to feel like a novelty
for their children these reimagined
decorations have made their homes more
magical when I saw the decorations I was
like oh it's something that can
represent me
and it just really like bring light to
his house the other day I went to a shop
and we found a wrapping paper and it had
mostly white people on but like one
small black person on the bottom so it
feels like nice to feel like that March
music is here to like support around us
representation for all of us has come a
long way but now so many more can have a
Christmas that feels more like them
ashnar and agas in South London
sometimes we have to rely on children to
point out the absolute obvious well
let's bring you more now on our top
story the head of Passenger operations
at Services uh at Gatwick Airport has
told the program this morning the
passport checks are moving smoothly so
far after border four staff began strike
action today however there are warnings
of bigger delays at airports Nationwide
as the Christmas travel Rush gathers
Pace will joining me now to discuss this
is the General Secretary of the public
and Commercial Services Union Mark
sawatka a very good morning to you thank
you for joining us now of course you
represent uh the Border force staff
striking today and the dispute is
overpay pensions and conditions what is
currently on offer from the government
and what are your members demanding
uh well good morning and good morning to
your viewers
um well we've been given the lowest
payoffer anywhere in the economy the
government's given its own Workforce a
two percent pay raise
we're asking for 10 uh we're asking that
because inflation is over 10 percent
we've had 10 years where our pay has not
cap rate with inflation and currently
the government-owned staff
40 000 of them use food banks and 45 000
of them are so poor they're the
in-worker they have to claim the
benefits that in some case they
administer themselves from job centers
so we have a crisis of poverty in the
Civil Service and in addition the
government is telling people they're
going to slash tens of thousands of
their jobs and cut their redundancy
terms by 30 no one else faces attacks on
this scale and these are the people the
government clapped in the pandemic for
paying three million claims to Universal
Credit delivering the furlough scheme
keeping our justice system running on
our borders secure so it's not good
enough to clap them in the pandemic and
they'll give them the lowest pay raise
anywhere in the economy
now the head of Passenger operations at
Gatwick Airport has told us this morning
that things are smooth there are you
concerned that if there isn't disruption
if that if possible control does remain
smooth in these six airports that you
won't have a way of really forcing the
government's hand to offer you more
no well we'll see what happens across
the airports over the next few days that
the government's obviously gone to Great
cost to bring in the Army they're not
properly trained they're bringing people
in from all over the country to try and
paper over the cracks and the answer
isn't to try and paper over the cracks
or bring the Army in it's to recognize
that it's not sustainable to give us the
lowest payoff anywhere when such poverty
exists and then refuse to talk about the
issue of pay but what the government
knows is that so far we have had about 5
000 members on strike we've been on
strike in driving tests on our motorways
in the river payments agencies and in
some job centers but a hundred thousand
people have voted to go on strike and so
in January if the government still
refuse to talk despite what's going to
happen at our airports on our roads with
our driving tests and with payments to
Farmers the strike will escalate
significantly and I also believe other
public sector workers will make the same
choice we know that hundreds of
thousands of teachers for example are
currently balled him for industrial
action and the answer to this is not
this disruption it's not to talk about
strikes it's to get government ministers
to front up not be missing in action
talk about pay and let us get back to
providing the services that our members
want to be providing now we're already
hearing uh strike dates announced for
other sectors ambulance workers nurses
were expecting to hear about too
can we expect more strikes from border
four staff in January and what does
escalation look like when it comes to
your industrial action
so escalation for us I mean yesterday we
served notice to bring members out on
strike in the dvla which is going to
affect significantly the issue of
driving licenses for example but we also
have members who voted to strike who
issued passports people who work in
every major government Department
including our job center Network and our
benefits Network so a hundred thousand
people are voted to strike all of them
are struggling all of them are poorer at
the end of the year than they were at
the start even though they worked harder
than ever before so escalation in the
Civil Service will mean every government
Department begins to be affected and
within the home office itself at the
moment we've called out staff in the
airports but of course there are other
areas like Dover for example and other
ports across the UK that members would
be called out to take strike action on
but I hope none of that happens and I
hope a government Minister comes on to
explain why his their own Workforce are
living in poverty and they will not give
them a penny above 2 percent which is
not what they're saying to anybody else
in the economy
well it's it's quite clear that the
government is not going to be offering
an 11 pay rise what compromise would you
accept
well we've asked for 10
um and we've asked for assurances there
won't be redundancies I mean your
viewers may be amazed to know there's
over a thousand people working in the
job centers at the moment facing
redundancies even though you need more
people delivering welfare in a cost of
living crisis than ever before if the
government says they'll put money on the
table we are prepared to negotiate where
that goes who gets it when and where and
how quickly they get it but we want
money now because the crisis is now we
are not saying it's 10 or we won't talk
to you we're saying put money on the
table and we are prepared to negotiate
but the government will not do that and
they keep hiding behind this claim that
is independent paid of your bodies but
they know there is no independent paid
everybody in the Civil Service they've
chosen to give their own Workforce the
lowest pay raise of any part of the
economy and that is not acceptable
now National highways staff are also on
strike today the first of four days of
industrial action they're also members
of your union what's your message uh to
people trying to get home for Christmas
who are now really worried about their
plans having had a really tough couple
of years with covid and now facing this
disruption at the border on the roads
what would you say to them
well what I say to them and also the
people whose driving tests have been
canceled and the farmers who are
struggling to get payments from the
rural payments agency is the government
we're told six months ago that this was
going to happen they were told three
weeks ago that these particular strikes
were going to happen and yet they have
not agreed to have a single meeting with
us all agreed to put a single penny on
the table so anyone who faces disruption
you have a right to be angry but your
anger should be directed at Richie sunac
and Jeremy Hunt they could stop these
strikes today they are choosing not to
that is a disgraceful way to treat some
of the hardest working men and women in
this country and if they maintain that
stance these strikes will only grow and
escalate I don't want to see that but
what I do want to see is an end to end
with poverty and only the government can
end that by giving us the pay raise we
deserve
uh now soldiers and civil servants who
are Manning uh passport control at
airports today have had reportedly
around five days of training uh for this
what are your members who work for
Border Force saying about the problems
that could arise from that
well we all know and and Sue Ella
Braverman knows uh that giving people
five days training uh is no substitute
for the skilled job that our members do
because this is not just about checking
passports these are people who are
trained over many months and years on on
the job training to be able to deal with
issues at the passport control including
for example looking out for victims of
people trafficking looking out for
people in a vulnerable situation looking
out for people who may not be all that
they seem and that takes skill takes
skill to spot it and skill to deal with
it having squatties turn up with no
training to paper over the cracks is not
the answer and what the government needs
to ask itself is it's got military
personnel driving ambulances and now at
our borders are they going to teach our
children Drive our chain trains pay
Universal Credit collect our taxes of
course they can't the Army is no
substitute for public sector workers we
all know this and we also all know that
the government could end this today and
I'll make this final point point
what we're asking for is a tiny fraction
of what the government was prepared to
borrow to give tax cuts to the richest
people in Britain if they were prepared
to do that for the richest why can't
they find a fraction of the money for
Job Center workers border force staff
rural payments agency staff paramedics
nurses and train workers we deserve it
the public know that we deserve it yet
the government has gone missing in
action and they are to blame for the
disruption okay Mark sawka we appreciate
your time today thanks very much Dave
for joining us thanks very much
let's have a quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
sponsored by Qatar Airways
the mostly mild and changeable weather
will bring some wet conditions to the
roads in the run-up to Christmas
especially today when those roads are so
busy for now rain is taking over more of
Ireland and Southern Britain where it's
been quite foggy too but the north is
mainly fine if a little chilly the rain
heavy in places will Edge further North
during this morning allowing the
Southwest to brighten up but showers are
likely there too meanwhile Northern
Britain will stay mainly dry with a few
Sunny spells but there will be a few
showers around too and they'll be mainly
wintry on the Scottish Hills and across
Shetland it'll be colder than yesterday
in the north milder in the South but
windier for everyone and this afternoon
we'll see rain spreading across Northern
Ireland Northern England and Scotland
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
you're watching Sky News still to come
we'll be taking a closer look at the
stories dominating today's papers in the
Pay-Per-View
it's time now for our paper review with
the broadcaster and journalist afia
Hagan and Mary McLeod a former policy
advisor to the queen and Royal household
who also served as a conservative MP hi
against you both Mary I'm just going to
pick up with you first if I may just on
that story we were talking about at the
end of the last hour on the front page
of the mirror today that King Charles
security has been stepped up now of
course you were a policy advisor to the
queen of Royal household what's your
take on this is is this something to be
concerned about
well I mean the his majesty security is
essential and his protection officers do
an amazing job I mean I've seen just
even recently and with business in the
community we had our responsible
business live event just two weeks ago
the fourth year celebration and the King
was there
um and a really important moment for him
to be out and about and being seen for
the work that he has done over the years
on sustainability on the race Charter
getting businesses connected into local
communities so you know and after the
event he went out and did a brief walk
um very informally with the public and I
do think it's great that they can engage
with him in in more personal ways so I
think
um the protection officers and the
security detail will will do their the
due diligence they will do their job but
it's always right that they
um make sure that his security comes
first
okay fear uh the mail you've pulled out
this story on page 11 of course there's
the cost of living crisis hits people
around the country pretty worrying
headline here that half of people are
buying less food as of course food
prices have been soaring much higher
than the average inflation
that's right and at a time where a lot
of people are considering their
Christmas food shop or perhaps they've
already done it and this piece in the
middle saying that half of adults are
buying less food amid soaring braces and
this is Raising Health years because the
numbers are even higher for those in
deprived areas and that about 61 of
people in the most deprived areas are
buying less food that's compared to 44
in other areas and we've seen the price
of food uh so really exponentially over
the past few months as as you say we're
deep into this cost of living crisis uh
the past the price of vegetable oil up
65 passes up 60 Apples Up 17 Tomatoes up
19 so people are really experi feeling
the Crunch and the fear is that people
are not eating as healthily as they
could be and as they should be simply
because they can't afford to also says
here that people are eating laced meals
as well as well as buying less food
they're skipping meals they're eating
less meals and people really feeling
like the cost of living crisis the high
cost of food is affecting how much they
can eat and of course like I said this
is higher end deprived areas and this is
sparking healthy is that people aren't
getting the nutrients they need they're
switching to cheaper alternatives
processed foods that are not going to be
as nutritious and like I said gifting
meals so they're not even even eating as
much as they should be in the first
place yeah it's certainly just desperate
isn't it and so worrying these reports
are so many people especially parents
missing meals to make ends meet
um Mary another pretty Grim Rapport and
of course news that the British public
are facing is is all this disruption
with Travelers we're going to Christmas
uh you know people coming into the UK
for Christmas will not only be impacted
at airports with border Force strikes
but also then on the rails if they need
to get a train after they arrive
tomorrow and could be families that are
that are most disrupted
yes a really difficult Story I mean
there's travel disruption the border for
strikes ruled real air chaos in a more
industrial action and it's and it's
really difficult because it does affect
families doing things they're traveling
at at Christmas all in a major airports
sex airports are affected by this
um and and even just people coming to do
family events traveling to their
families or if they're going to football
marches or whatever it might be you know
it's just it's it's going to affect
um everybody this and
um and and where you know certainly the
military and civil servants are stepping
in to review passports at airports
um and but of course the those things
will hopefully help and airports are
telling us not to be too worried but we
just have to me make sure we build in
that time when we're traveling trying
not to get stressed about it there will
be longer use and airports are saying
they don't think there'll be
cancellations but of course many people
can use the e-gates and the biometric
passports although that's children can't
do that so you know hopefully families
will be moved up to the front of cues at
at airports but yeah it's going to be
difficult so I think probably if people
expect it's going to be difficult then
just leave sort of Plenty time
um to to get where you want to want to
be but you know this is a time for
friends family loved ones to get
together and and therefore let's hope
that people can still do that yeah
absolutely I mean traveling Christmas is
stressful enough isn't it without all
this extra disruption pack snacks is my
advice pack snacks now at the start afia
you pulled out this article about uh
Jeremy Clarkson uh you know the the
criticism of his comments about Meghan
Markle rumbles on
yeah absolutely it does
um it's sort of a weirdly written piece
in the Daily Star here by Will Stone
doesn't actually name Meghan Markle has
the picture of her there with her eyes
like for some reason not really very
sure why but yes uh this is uh still the
criticism of Jeremy Clarkson's column
that he wrote In The Sun where he wrote
some really uh disgusting comments about
Meghan Markle and how much he hate the
dark and what he wanted to see happen to
her and know some people that support
um heart and and basically say that what
he said was terrible it was out of order
and are sort of raising money for this
legal battle so they've raised twelve
thousand pounds uh to bring you know a
case to court against him not really
sure why they would do that Meghan
Markle you know took on The Daily Mail
she clearly has the funds to be able to
fund the legal battle herself if she
wanted to but I guess this is just more
of the Fallout
um from that column being printed in the
Sun and just shows you the depth of
people's reactions to it how many people
uh how it continued to say that what he
said was absolutely wrong yeah
absolutely it certainly feels like it's
not going to go away for a while does it
fear Mary thank you both so much we'll
see you again in the next hour
[Music]